j'ai envie de vous d'aller chanter moi
oh là c'est ce que je voudrais mais j'ai
pas la voix
[Musique]
ce sont les petites fleurs du pavé de
Paris il en faut
qu'un soleil timide pointe son nez que
reviennent alors le temps du muguet le
temps des cerises Le Bon Temps le temps
d'aimer le temps des vacances le temps
de prendre un verre ou deux et vous les
voyez pousser devant les terrasses de
Saint-Germain-des-Prés où chacun sait
qu'on ne perd pensant tant que ailleurs
qui
ose prétendre qu'il n'y a plus d'après
Saint-Germain-des-Prés plus d'après et
les après-midi alors c'est merveilleux
après-midi où l'on fait le lézard
décoratif aux terrasses tandis que de
coindru en coin de rue de bistrot en
bistrot cette musique d'accordéon vous
suit comme une ombre comme un chien
comme un vieil amour
évidemment ça ne plaît pas à tout le
monde
musicien qui a de la terrasse plein et
puis alors surtout le soir il y a
beaucoup de monde alors il y a des des
guitaristes des musiciens des chantiers
qui viennent chanter pour la musée la
galerie parmi il y aura des matchs
vraiment la clientèle
désagréable comme tout
est-ce que vous avez quelquefois des
scandales
il y en a eu des scandales aussi
qu'est-ce que vous voulez pas bien ça
fait partie de la du charme de Paris
monsieur moi monsieur je ne peux pas
comprendre moi monsieur moi monsieur
pourquoi les militaires ne m'ont pas
accepté écrivant à mon père de son fils
est un
rêve et qu'ils n'en ont vraiment que
faire mais qui est dans l'ombrement te
faire
[Musique]
maintenant se plaisent davantage sur la
côte parce qu'ils ont constaté qu'ils
peuvent en même temps que gagner leur
vie très substantiellement avec en
chantant dans les rues passer d'agréable
vacances alors je crois qu'il y en a
beaucoup sur la côte
en sommes je vais vous habitués
qui viennent tous les ans
et vos clients comment
les clients c'est une espèce
d'atmosphère qui qui leur déplaît pas je
crois j'aime bien les guitaristes
d'abord parce que c'est joué par une
génération plus jeune par des musiciens
qui sont beaucoup plus jeunes que ceux
qui qui joue de l'accordéon et ensuite
parce que les airs qui jouent sur la
guitare sont plus modernes les plus près
de moi c'est Guignols musiciens est-ce
qu'on se fâche contre guignols
que la nuit tombe et les tables qui
attendent des patiemment leur heure en
rang comme dans la cour de récréation se
mettent à vivre
elles font le monôme le long du trottoir
Ennery elles font la fête et les
musiciens comme le laveur de
Prévert réapparaissent il réapparaissent
en renféré c'est l'offensive général des
musiques du trottoir
les guitares partent en patrouille il y
a des airs en embuscade
la rue mobilise pour sa ronde de nuit
[Musique]
beaucoup de valve c'est déjà pas mal ici
c'est pas un climat de guerre non ici on
passe aussi mutant les mains en
guitariste un accordéoniste
non c'est à dire qu'en fait ils essayent
de passer les premiers parce que s'il
passe la dernière l'autre il est certain
que la recette de s'en ressentir
ça aussi j'aimerais mais j'ai pas les
moyens
[Musique]
en vérité ces trains de savate
sympathiques et pas méchant c'est
bohémiens de Paris c'est troubadour de
la casquette tendue ce sont les santons
de la rue quand les enlève du village de
Saint-Germain et le décor il perdra sa
couleur on les retire et la poésie
canaille partira avec eux
pour la bonne raison et que deuxièmement
sur le trottoir je n'ai rien à je n'ai
pas faire la police du trottoir c'est
appartient à la police officielle et pas
la femme en service personnel ils sont
extrêmement bruyants ce qui est très
fâcheux
dans une soirée ça n'a pas d'importance
mais quand c'est une un défilé continuel
à partir de 8h du soir de de cris de
toutes sortes et de musique ou
autre c'est ça devient extrêmement
fatiguant et vraiment en désagréable à
la longue son défenseur
toujours des étrangers je les Américains
nordiques américains
[Musique]
les après-midi les après-midi les après
soupés on en finit plus les souvenirs de
tout à l'heure déjà donnent la main à se
dire mais des musiciens de l'été ne
vieillissent pas plus que les masques de
Michael alors on les accepte
regardez-les ce sont nos frères comme
nous il descendent dans la nuit le temps
de leurs années
[Musique]